y realmente demuestra esa gran división
que ya venimos viendo desde hace semanas
dentro de las fuerzas rusas lo que él
dice Es que asumes le prometieron que le
iban dar más munición que él asegura que
no ha llegado esto después de que las
fuerzas wagners quienes han liderado esa
batalla por bakmuth desde hace más de
ocho meses desde verano que empezaron
esta ofensiva pues hayan avanzado con
mayor velocidad en la última semana como
nos confesaban nos contaban los soldados
ucranianos en el terreno hace pocos días
que estuvimos allí esto también lo que
demuestra es que si Wagner se retira
obviamente como él dice dejaría
básicamente en momento de debilidad de
las fuerzas rusas que son minoría el
ejército en ese frente ellos atacan
muchas veces apoyando ya después de que
las fuerzas wagners han enviado cientos
y cientos de hombres para morir pero de
todas maneras lo que más que todo Deja
en evidencia es esa continua división
que hay dentro de las fuerzas rusas y
Que obviamente juega En beneficio de
Ucrania entre tanto Catalina Cuál es la
denuncia de los soldados ucranianos en
medio de esta batalla por bamus
más que una denuncia es unas preguntas
que se hacen y lo recogía y uno hoy uno
de los medios más importantes en Ucrania
de gif Independencia lo que dicen
algunos soldados en el frente es qué
tanto vale la pena desgastarnos en esta
lucha por backmud una ciudad que está
prácticamente destruida en vez de
retirarnos a posiciones mucho más
fuertes a poblaciones como
Constantinopla o proteger slobians y así
fortalecer y cuidar a los hombres para
la llamada ofensiva que está esperando
Ucrania en esa Región del Sur del
saporilla que comunica con Mario poli y
que va directamente a crimea y que busca
cortar las líneas de abastecimiento de
los de las fuerzas rusas esto lo tienen
planeado cuando entre el mejor tiempo en
la primavera y ellos se preguntan que si
no es mejor conservar a los hombres
cuando lleguen las armas que les va a
dar Europa nuevamente con esas nuevas
municiones y poder avanzar ahí pero son
simplemente preguntas ellos confiesan
que ha sido una batalla muy difícil como
lo reconocía anoche mismo el presidente
bola dormirse lensky que decía que tal
vez era una de las batallas más fuertes
que se han peleado en Ucrania en el
último año y ellos se han ido vendiendo
retirando en backboot y se han centrado
en una parte de la ciudad que todavía
controlan los ucranianos